[Music]
as opposed to the Wailing Wall in
Waterford Wisconsin mama quickly why is
the kid having to go get more eggs I had
more than two in the initial basket he
brought I blame the chicken if his
eggs-cruciating li exaggerated pursuit
of excellence didn't need them to be
exactly the same size why did he expel
the first pair of eggs by simple visual
examination what you think I could
resist egg puns my karma let that happen
I know the doctor who said whatnot it is
not the it is the imbalance Ruby gets
hercule poirot confused with Adrian Monk
so I'll give me I am benjin that's Belle
just in the Church of the Holy Sepulchre
above us there's actually nothing above
them except a wall and while Poirot
might have not meant exactly above us
the church he speaks of is not by the
Wailing Wall it's in the Christian
quarter of Jerusalem the Wailing Wall is
by the Dome of the rock which is an
Islamic shrine I mean of course the
chief inspector of the police and do I
believe now does regret inviting me to
consult on this case why would he invite
anyone to consult in this case when you
can just pin it on whomever you like
somebody was paying attention in police
corruption want to want also if you're
going to pick an inspector why the one
who was known as the best detective in
the world did you search the office as I
asked
yes and did you find what I said you
might yes sir the chief inspector
decided yeah I stole this priceless
relic so I'll keep it in a bag in my
office no detective we'll look there
I get that this is to set up waro super
advanced Jedi ninja detective powers but
the chief was standing right here when
he sent the armed guard to the gate and
came this wall so what are the chances
he still runs straight toward these
things I can only see the world as it
should be and when it is not the
imperfection stands out like the nose in
the middle of my face or like two
mustaches fighting under the nose for
dominance ray and Gilderoy Lockhart
finally in a scene together and one
Schippers fan fiction universe crossing
sexy might finally come true Hercules
para lq Wow
I do not slay the Lions god bless a
movie that gives a clearer primer on
name pronunciation otherwise I might end
up calling a character named Lara Laura
for two straight videos and not even
know it that would be a nightmare you
are from of the British country in the
faro gets a telegram from London which
means he's going to have to go there to
solve the case
time to take a train a train that will
just happen to be the setting for a
murder committed by twelve people and
require the exact knowledge he possesses
to solve Kenneth Branagh has an
incredible sense of how to use the
camera this tracking shot from outside
following this conversation is just one
of the many examples of beautiful
camerawork in this movie which all
together are worthy of a sin removal
with the arrival of Judi Dench the
long-awaited Pirates of the Caribbean on
Stranger Tides reunion with Penelope
Cruz and Johnny Depp is finally complete
no no if the Train is fully booked as
was stated earlier then how is princess
dragomiroff getting extra options dogs
on the table most disgusting thing I was
seen alive
two dogs one cup
it's this excited about a train leaving
seeing doesn't that mean is me actually
we love you Penelope we even go to bat
for Vanilla Sky but then again you were
in Zoolander 2 so you know there's
something about a tangle of strangers
pressed together for days on end with
nothing in common boredom plus anonymity
plus a constant gentle rocking someone's
been hanging out in our comment section
not all of us are so concerned with the
separateness of racist professor it is
out of respect for all kinds that I
prefer to keep them separate to mix your
red wine and the white would be to rule
them both so we're gonna solve racism
ladies and gentlemen we symbolically mix
red and white wines I like a good rosy
as do I but a rosy is essentially a red
wine that doesn't incorporate all the
color from the grape skins it's not like
the Arnold Palmer ones the Avenger of
the innocent when they call you in the
papers borrows an Avenger too honestly
there's so many characters set to be an
infinity war that actually wouldn't
surprise me to see her cool hanging out
a few scenes measuring bounces Infinity
stones to make sure they were the same
Suns
catallena movie wastes our time with
love interest that will barely come up
again when all we care about is that the
great moustache detective get back to
some hardcore detecting it was a great
joke earlier when Hercule revealed his
sleepytime upper lip pulse tree
protector so why is he leaving his mouth
brow uncovered tonight especially with
his OCD tendencies the snow from the
Avalanche was clearly falling right on
top of the Train in the previous shop
but here it appears to all be in front
of the train considering they were
traveling along the side of a mountain
derailment should have been crashing to
their deaths yes some things they are in
God's hands it is not for us to say if
we deserve to arrive safely at our
destination or if like Lucifer
we must before she's fun touch nothing
else only the buddy movie takes 38
minutes to murder when I was promised
Murder on the Orient Express
better learn how to spell if you're
gonna send threatening letters have you
considered the Latin man Marquez hell of
a guy and well you know this guy they
don't have the same distaste for murder
since we eventually find out all the
passengers in this coach - Baro are in
on the murder why would they point their
fingers at each other instead of just
staying out of it watch stopped at 1:15
and perhaps more importantly it's
somehow still on that table after the
train derailed we saw stuff flying
everywhere during the Avalanche
so how is any of this still on the table
for that matter how was this wretched
wretched corpse even still on the bed
and later around here a lady's
handkerchief friendly now how did these
clues get left here I don't even leave a
hotel room without doing a quick
once-over for something I left behind
and I'm not even part of an organized
stabbing orgy usually also the stabbing
took place for a brief moment in the
middle of the night why would they even
have those things with the this was
never a beachside puzzle it certainly
doesn't appear to be beachside but come
to think of it neither of you really
look gold and I haven't seen a single
characters breath yet maybe it's a dry
coal I know the dead man's real name it
is not ratchet but Cassetti
I know that name then you will also know
the name Armstrong but how does he know
this the murder tying in with the
Armstrong case is perfectly fine it's a
fascinating story that sets up a
fascinating mystery but Poirot should
have never come upon this information as
quickly there has been nothing to lead
him to believe that ratchet is Cassetti
he might as well as said he was Arnold
Rothstein or someone involved in the st.
Valentine's Day Massacre the Armstrong
case the story shocked the world
monochromatic exposition exposition how
do you know this Parra
because Joan Armstrong told me so
himself he wrote to me to ask me for my
help
by the time I received his letter it was
too late conveniently all this was
falling into my lap again I have proof
it's true I found it at the foot of my
bed on the cover right where I slept
what do you call that blackout drunk sex
with an Orient Express conductor easy to
wear easy I would not be famous why
exactly is Paro famous he's a very
intelligent sleuth who has helped solve
a ton of murders and other crimes but at
the end of the day he's an excellent
crime consultant how many of those do
you know human nature its buffs in its
complexity to a plumb it takes the right
tools these are toys not tools thank you
I prefer you put them away we are still
talking about the whole murder thing
right because you just said not now when
we are done then no one can touch us
this is the conversation he's referring
to he's not even in the frame until she
says that nothing can touch us which
reminds me she said nothing not no one I
don't think you heard the conversation
anyway but you're together Poirot
were you ever acquainted with a family
by the name of Armstrong timely dog bark
is timely
why doesn't move here just use magic to
find the culprit that scarf obviously
means he's been sorted into house driven
door yes the conductor was a small man
with a short reign there is no other
conductor
knowing how this ends and that they all
conspired to do this together the fact
that they are such brilliant liars that
they all fool Paro as long as they do
and that they had time after the event
to get the same story straight is one of
the most unbelievable parts of this
entire film have we checked order the
passengers luggage remember them because
I sure don't the kilo is mocking me why
exactly what they put the items in poor
rose cases since the count and Countess
are involved and their luggage can't be
checked why not put it in there instead
of enraging para is Olaf with the shirt
on running away here exactly where does
he think he's going in this weather
in the mountains it's not even a rugby
team from Uruguay around for if he gets
hungry wiper in this evidence when it's
quicker and more effective to just throw
it down in the ravine or buried in the
snow they tore my old man apart and yet
you claim that you did not know ratchet
was Cassetti
one thing this movie does a terrible job
of is showing how anyone knows ratchet
was Cassetti Paro makes it a simple
statement in fact early on in the movie
but with no connection whatsoever
alright this needs to come out once
again this is how you dispose of the
evidence there is so much snow around
these people not know how to hide things
and other things this is suddenly
materializing pianist reveals a good
question why aren't any of the rail
staff being questioned by Paro for that
matter what have they all been this
entire time also suddenly materializing
pianist is likely the working title for
the eventual Weinstein documentary the
actress mother stage name Linda Arden I
suppose she too was of Jewish ancestry
as who is most likely to take a stage
name is it too far to suggest her
original name was Goldenberg my question
is since you know that this murder has
something to do with the Armstrong case
why didn't you already know the name
Goldenberg surely that was Sonia
Armstrong's maiden name as well and you
ran across it before
she didn't kill him I did Aaron Berger
misses also where exactly is this semi
false confession taking place we know
there are only four cars on this train
and we've seen one sleeper car a dining
car a bar car and we heard Baro say Buch
was the only chatarrero stepped in
another coach or the only one who is not
a suspect which I assume means staff
quarters even if they are in the same
boxcar is the baggage car seen here
which is unlikely that's still one too
many boxcars I deduce a missing car
who's the detective now smirky her key
Mary go
Oh God let you take the pain but you
can't be held for accessory to murder if
you leave now and let him kill Poirot
our plan was to reveal him to the police
that's what you had come to think of it
why didn't they just do that and the
book he's actually exonerated at trial
and they have no choice to get their own
justice but here he simply avoided
prosecution wouldn't at least one in
this murder cult press for due process
and now mr. Poirot I must protect myself
from him locking the Train off the
blocks ex machina and then the Deus Ex
book enough where did they put all the
other passengers that were in the other
cars while they put the train back on
the track also imitating the Last Supper
with your movie characters cliche I mean
I saw this in history of the world part
1 I saw it in mash I saw it in that 70
show can we stop this already it was you
was it not in our room the night when
ratchet came in through the window wait
if she saw ratchet that night how on
earth was that poor Suzanne girl that
committed suicide for false accusation
ever even charged with the police of at
least gone as far as to ask the gender
of the intruder from the lone eyewitness
would he chauffeur agree was it a bank
loan secured by Armstrong allows him to
build his automobile empire how exactly
did all these people find each other the
sister was friends with the governess
but how did the cook the nurse the valet
and the chauffeur all get tracked down
what are the chances McQueen and
Masterman could conveniently get hired
on with ratchet not to mention Hardman
just happened to be in the area when
ratchet needed someone to tail him also
if you had successfully gotten into
ratchets inner circle why take the pains
murdering him on a train why not do it
at his house you could literally do
everything you did here except in that
scenario you could easily get away with
it also also how exactly were they
planning on getting away with this mind
you they did not expect to be stuck due
to the avalanche of convenience right
after the murder and they had no clue
Hercule Poirot would be on the train but
they would still have had to deal with
the police at the next stop and figuring
out who ratchet was and their attachment
to the Armstrong case would not have
been that hard to deduce what the
Pinkerton Detective once police officers
are assigned to the Armstrong case and
he becomes attached to someone for there
is another uncelebrated victim you fell
in love with the maid figuring out the
detective was a cop on the Armstrong
case makes sense but how would Paro know
he was in love with a mate
also if Hartman is in on this the whole
time then why is he doing the
play-acting at all once again no one
knew Poirot would be there and even if
he's supposed to be helping ratchet he
wouldn't have cared what Hardman did as
long as he protected it pl Michel of
Ivania
who lost his sister the accused made
Suzanne Michel by the way how are all
these people able to procure the same
car that just happened to have the exact
amount of rooms they need it this is
clearly a very popular train and it was
sold out which is why Paro had to bunk
with McQueen he can only have been done
by all of you Jesus I'm glad you finally
came to this conclusion after seeing
what must have been 2000 coincidences on
this train also yep they all did it this
Baker's Dirty Dozen all conspired to
kill it but look at them in this
decent-sized room and then imagine them
all in one tiny railcar taking turns
with a knife because the reason they
don't show any wide-shots in the
reenactment I'm not saying they couldn't
a squeezed in there I'm just saying if
they did the murderer would have been
like trying to have an orgy in an
airplane bathroom soy fur as alert as
Baro has been this whole movie two
sounds outside his room it seems a
little odd that he never poked his head
out once while all of them were standing
outside
[Music]
since we now know everybody including
the conductor was in on it why did he
even bother to knock on the door
why did Caroline respond in French if
she didn't know Paro was snooping around
and if this was staged why did they even
bother let it end with me they're not
killers I mean but some of them are mind
you some of them just stabbed did it
body but semantics also why not just let
Masterman take the blame
you'll be dead in a couple of months
selfish Masterman you wish to go free
without punishment for your crime then
you must only come meet one more you got
let them kill you well and they would
have had to kill book as well right
along with everyone else working on the
Train and in the Train so just 20 more I
already died with Daisy this is the
return of the king of murder mystery
endings my dear Colonel Armstrong
finally I can answer your letter I know
you're dead but this is a great way for
me to end the movie with my closing
thoughts I'm looking for a mr. Poirot
he's needed on a very urgent matter yeah
he is on oily dig but he was taking this
train to help out with the Kastner case
so why is he still on with this holiday
business I have to take him to Egypt
straightaway there's been a murder sir
right on the bloody Nile obvious equals
obvious
[Applause]
here accidents happen all the time what
makes you think it was murder
I blame the chicken that seems you dolt
apart from you they're the most stupid
creatures on this planet
my name is fq papa
you killed my father prepare to die
friend the pipe cleaner yes a riot of
cool this is what we call an orgy of
evidence do you ever go by honey what
happens if the engine stops we are for
the great Hercules Poirot
Oh leave Leave leave why aren't you dead
yet got better